as a beginning player I had a great deal
of difficulty and not losing right away
like I would be making all sorts of
wrong moves and it was only after you
know a terrible terrible pounding being
beaten like a drum that I came up with
my own ideas about what I should do in
the opening and one of the things I
started to doing when I was both on the
black site as well as the White Army was
I would create a fortress or what I
imagined to be a fortress my opening
movie who was white was d2 d3 it's not a
particularly good move but I'm just
explaining how I kind of evolved and
like thinking so why did I do that well
you'll see in a moment
it's almost against any move that black
could conceive for example black might
conceive of moving his morning yeah
which is a very natural move in the
opening to try to occupy the center my
response was developed by nine let's say
he in turn develops his line and my
response was to play g3 so the idea and
again kind of my childish imagination
was that my bishops need to defeat on
the long diagonal it was going to be
very effective so I would play g3 and it
doesn't matter what my phone
for example my opponent I play c5 I play
Bishop g2 my opponent might for example
by knight c6 I would Castle so in this
way what I was thinking was I'm gonna
lose the game okay we already know I'm
gonna lose the game that goes without
saying because I just simply didn't know
what I was doing but I'm not going to
lose the game two or four or six moves I
put my king and what I conceived is my
fortress I would my nice shield stands
in front of my king using extra
protection - good protects my king so my
king I imagine was in some kind of a
portrait then long term my idea was that
this Bishop was on this diagonal and I
should clear a path so for example my
opponent would play a move like me find
again a very reasonable move capturing
good controlling the center occupying
the center in my mind what I should do
is I should knock this guy out away so
if I could get my opponent to play a
move for example like d4 I I was very
pleased because I thought hey long term
you know that Bishop is like on a really
good diagonal but maybe one day I get
really lucky and I capture his rook here
so why did I play the new d3 on my open
well the reason that place be three is
because what would happen to me when I
was black keeping in mind that what I
wanted to do me I was black a white it
didn't matter was create a fortress this
happened to me several times from the
starting position as white
keeping in mind my wonderful experienced
opponent would play E for now I would
play Knight f6 my opponent would attack
my knight I would try to create shadow
and make a fortress and my opponent
would take my knight in the game and I
already lost my gavel era that was
really terrible so an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure and
I'll pay me for d6 so he went here I
immediately went here of course he would
he would play here I'm not even sure to
even occur to me by the way that was
necessarily attacking his palm that had
nothing to do with the concept of what I
wanted to do what I wanted to do was
simply be shed of my King's Bishop and I
don't really care I mean some would like
check by the way I think I would have
tried the castle because I just knew
what I wanted to do I wanted to get that
set up
I had my fortress and then I'd lose and
that was okay but a sheriff be getting
checkmated in three moves which also
have to do
of course when I tried to do copy my
opponent so here of course I would
today we just thank my opponent for the
tempo and I played c6 blocking the trick
then finding excellent castles
I also remember has a very good memory
of this happening to me I was white and
again this isn't in my beginning days
and fully and understand why I should be
doing so I opened up with a move like d3
so only much later when I headed ball
than ahead advance with my knowledge of
chess it taken a quantum leap forward
did I understand that I should make a
fortress at this moment I didn't occur
to me that I should make a fortress my
opponent played remove d5 so I played
before
very very crafty right copying my
opponent figure and you know like I
would mimic exactly the moves of my
opponent until you know brilliance took
over and I would play my own move so he
played ePHI I play d4 ok copying like
figuring this out like like like play
along here for a moment and my opponent
plays Bishop g4 cores this is a terrible
simply take the darn bishop so I didn't
consider that my main move was Bishop g5
try copying my opponent but something
smelled wrong like man those pawns were
in great conflict with one another like
whoa you know like okay here's where I
figured I should take one of the other
and I couldn't quite decide so I went
captures which is a great move right you
know the advantage now my opponent
played an incredibly remarkable movies
yes bishop takes game that would be that
would be a very very strong but he
played even a much more remarkable more
than that
he went Bishop before check and mate Wow
he explained to me that those bishops my
King couldn't move my King couldn't move
he had me Wow I could be like I could
put my knight in the way no this gets
even better a guy is walking along it is
not gonna park right he walks along he
looks it good wow that's a great
checkmate so you know confirmation let's
oh you think I was good
no I wasn't born good I was born down
our lives as a horrible horrible chess
play would lose all my games beatin like
a drum somebody would point out that I
was checkmated what can I tell you so
one of the real difficulties I had to
overcome both as a beginning novice
player as well as once I started getting
a rating and things like that was
finding an opening defenses that I found
suitable and again as I started this
lecture I wanted to throw it back at
yourselves and say do anybody have
questions about openings and not take
you through them and how I started
thinking about openings and
what I get so please Queens gap it's
good running or selling creams gambit
okay
accepted or declined exactly so it's
it's very funny today that in chess
there are basically two main white can
play E for occupying the center or D for
occupying the same so at one time I
played keyboard that came later because
I read that Bobby Fischer said e bar was
best for me I'll play for when I didn't
realize dissidents but probably the
single most heavily analyzed opening for
white and that the black players of
their experience will have their defense
is really well researched and I was
forever forever behind the 8-ball so to
speak in Mike there and aplomb knowledge
of before later in life I would play c4
because this was a less trodden path
this was the English opening and I I
didn't have to learn so much opening
theory then much later when I became a
very strong Grandmaster I actually
started playing d4 almost exclusively
okay so let's see what the pluses and
the minuses argue first of all in terms
of e for I mentioned already that
there's so much theoretical knowledge
that I needed that it was overwhelming
d4 equally there's a lot of theoretical
knowledge
one of the things I liked about d4 or at
least I involved in my thinking I came
to like about d4 is that it wasn't so
sharp in other words the openings were
softer it wasn't like in e4 you know the
beginning could hinge on a single tempo
or single turn so I like d4 and I came
to like it this now from blacks point of
view all this tons of millisecond play
as tons of doors you like c5 you can
play b5 you can play deep by the e5
Knight f6 he could play g6 a kind of a
modern classically speaking d5 isn't the
oldest response to d4 and understandably
so white takes space in the center a
black in turn takes space in the center
now after hundreds of years it's
considered that c4 is the natural
follow-up and we get what is called a
Queens gambit so it gets the term gambit
because it does a popper black the
opportunity of capturing this pawn of he
likes and so now there's the Queens
gambit accepted there's what is called
the Queens gambit declined g6 this is
probably the oldest move and there is
what is called the Slav defense so the
SOB defenses black plays c7 c6 and
fortifies his Center so he's willing to
trade
defense has one small drawback one small
drawback the night army needs you just
occupied my best squared dude there you
sure you want to do that
how do you fall off the paint game it
you would please name accepted and then
he takes okay so we have for example the
Queens gambit accepted well when I was
starting chess you know it really really
troubled me then my opponent captured a
pawn and I wanted it back I wanted it
back really quickly so one thing I could
do is I could shag and I can take this
pawn back very quickly but later I would
learn that this move and thinking out
your queen early wasn't a very good idea
and I learned that III wasn't good
response now black could for example
play b5 to protect his bum but I can
still I can attack this point he can't
play a 6 because there's going to be a
pen on the rook so he could play c6
defending us I could take so in chess we
are properly taught and I think it's
absolutely accurate that we move our
pieces off the back reign of to help
develop them but sometimes on those rare
occasions it actually just turned out
right now I have
my work but my rooks development why is
that well it turns out that my rook has
this open file so the rook is actually
very useful on its original square and
live in movie 3 I'm I want to wind up on
that if my opponent to capture this pond
then I really like that just a minute to
you in Julian I really like this I was
told what this was called I don't
recapture the pond but I think an
intermezzo I thought that was such a
cool word once I learned what Intermezzo
was it's a an Italian move that Italian
word it means an in-between move before
I capture this I first captured this
pond would check and if he defends his
king by the way it's not Jeff made his
King I would take this pond and in the
development count I have one two three
four pieces developed or four units
developed and against his wand
Queen F so instead of b3 why not queen
m3 winning a piece each even stronger
even stronger like I said I was
mesmerized by wanting to win my pawn
back I mean winning a piece man whoa
whoa are you sure you devil sure I mean
you know what a win my poems so in the
Queens gambit accepted if we go back a
moment after the moon III the principal
line or what is called the main line is
night at 6:00 one other point if slack
plays Bishop e6 to defend his pawn
notice that the bishops not completely
comfortable standing in front of the e7
one I would play Knight 86
the 93 that they support and I still
managed to recapture this moment yeah
okay so so I'm doing the Queen's Gambit
would you like me to do the decline or
accept thank you okay fine
so after e3 my right the main line is
Bishop takes c4 and one of the ideas of
the Queens gambit accepted from blacks
point of view is it simply trying to
equalize these are these agreements are
considered the many many moves and this
very strange both a6 well what's the
idea of a six the idea behind a six is
to play beef
in Bishop e7 guess what
putting the bishop awful long diagonal
okay
an old favorite of mine as again way I'm
schooled in my thinking about the space
and time force upon structure King
position my classic knowledge of chess
tells me that I have a problem with
light in this position what's my problem
any guesses knocks coalition
dark-squared bishop thank you sir dark
spurt vision
so in my way of thinking I would play
the move
okay he's gonna put his Bishop on the
long diagonal I'm gonna do the same so
after move like be five I would go back
with my bishop and actually look like
they should be said of an initiative b7
thinking deeply into the position I
completely should be too which is a
perfectly legit move and I probably do
like - should be - I think importantly
they should be to Knight bg7 now I look
at mine item b1 mmm
the knight of b1 I'm a little bit
reluctant if I bring my Knight to c3
well I do step into a potential attack I
don't want to do that so I would plays a
little bit 84 very nice I'm attacking
this advanced pawn and after the movie 4
I look like
night unbe 152 so what my thinking is
I'm going to bring my night this square
which is a very nice outpost and also by
the way about during by night - this
square a lot of my opponents would
capture my pawn on b4 and I captured
with this month and I'll explain exactly
why in my opinion what blacks best piece
Whitesburg bishop so for me chess is
about recognizing my best square my best
pieces it's about recognizing your best
pizzas so after I play Knight takes my
idea will be the big vision f3 and
trading Jurgen piece for my lettuce aim
passive one if for example - 47 or we
can start to see how white is starting
to take over the board if there's a
train my Queen comes out and immediately
we start to notice there's a big big
weakness on the c6 squared my knight is
ready to jump to c6 we pressure on the
Queen and my rook is ready to come to
see one
the a bleep up my night is ready to come
to see form this is the white I wouldn't
like the Queen's get accepted what I was
waiting so I was about 14 or 15 years
old three four years into chess as this
type of parody
creaking became second nature and
somebody because name is bill McGarry
passed along 100 best parties akibo
Houston right so I started reading the
book and I read that a keeper Rubin team
was yeshiva scholar he had gone to
seminary to study Torah and he fell in
love with chess and he ran away and that
he at one time was considered the second
best player in the world to the world
champion and everybody thought that
Akiva Rubens team was going to play
against the manual aster for the World
Championship a match that didn't take
place because World War one interfered
and when I studied the games of Akiva
it's amazing with Lou Bernstein played
b3 and Bishop b2 I thought wow this guy
is good okay so how does a brief Queens
gambit accepted other openings from the
barbarian Northwest Northwest
very very very special place in Pacific
Northwest and in the early 70s there was
an extremely strong master player from
British Columbia his name was Robert
Zook three letters z UK and Bob's up he
was incredibly good at bringing out all
the sources developing his pieces
reaching the maximum that his pieces
could do and then can't reach what was
called we we called the zoo point so he
brought all his pieces out he brought
them all to the center he developed
everything and he didn't know what to do
he had anything that the plan you know
like okay and so we call this the suit
point you know you just bring out all
your pieces and then you wait for your
opponent to make mistake and he was very
very good and I think it was the the
winter of 1973-74 Bob's up went through
something like a hundred and ten games
without a single loss and won a hell of
a lot of games one tournament after
tournament and so I mean it's not the
worst thing they reach the zoo point but
to your to your point about efore okay
so
efore ePHI classical defense Knight f3
attacking apologize see 6 defending
apartment
Bishop b5 this
this move is attributed to a Spanish
priest by the name of rui lopez and so
it's from here from this position that
the ruler president derives its name and
in the fifteenth century a lot of moves
were tried d6 with the idea of Bishop d7
was the most common another move was 9g
equal aid to e7 defending the knight
defends the palm and then playing here
or playing here and then back in the
1850s a fella by the name of Paul Morphy
he came up with a revolutionary move
this was a seven a six
this became known as the morphe defense
wow that's so cool well why was that
move revolution well the thinking had
been that the knight defends ePHI the
bishop comes to attack the night so that
the knight can be captured
once the knight is captured the pawn can
be captured but nor if he demonstrated
then this was no threat it doesn't work
because there was a dump there was a
counter was after Knight takes Queen
Queen to d4 with a double attack
so morphe won several games like this
and that's the morphe defense so thanks
to Queen D for the idea of Bishop takes
c6 was started to be considered an
impotent threat that this was not
serious and black didn't have to worry
about it
so Bishop 84 became the standard move
can I just ask one question release my
several times I played Bishop things
night there and have actions and I know
books that you just be able to crush
that but I can't okay so Bishop pigs
so in case of context my understanding
and mechanic I my understanding is that
it starts with danger
okay in fact that so you don't have to
delay the capital recapture can take it
right time to Castle first no no you can
capture right away so my understanding
is that black now has two moves and only
to move the first move is Queen to e7
and the second move is Queen g5 Queen g5
attacking Knight attacking point and
then after something for example like d4
Queen eggs you get into a position and
endgame Arleen where it's considered
that after this trade that white has a
superior position thanks to his superior
center I mean it's still a game it's got
like you know another another thing is
in this position is in case he goes
Queen e2 not Queen g5 the queen e7 I beg
your pardon
I was blown I stole it I kept it
d4 protects the night
and now in case of the move d6 there is
90 x e6 queen takes e4 checked those
Queen e2 Queen takes e to King takes e 2
and we get into a position after Bishop
d7 to d5 sorry if I'm going a little bit
too fast but this is the basic stuff and
then the guy what takes two hits should
they be there she do
Knight here because he wants black wants
to win back his palm and the master the
master games that have resulted in this
kind of ending have ended up in White's
favor so that this move B takes c6 was
they stopped playing it because this
ending became favorable so the fact that
I lost him here was just but now that
I've shown you this I gotta share with
you a story of Boris Spassky
Boris Spassky was playing in the Soviet
championship and the Soviet
Championships that Boris Spassky
claimant wu-oh
burst from it was just amazing
essentially out of the 16 Republic's
that comprised the Soviet Union the very
very best of all the Republic's would
come and they would play its massive 20
player round-robin events that would
last for months and the getting to
compete just compete in the Soviet
championship was considered a phenomenal
invitation like you have to be one of
the best friend
in the world be able to compete in the
Soviet Union to win one of these Soviet
championships
we're just huge I mean then your work
then you were allowed it and in the
Soviet Union the chess grandmasters were
professional from the state they
received a apartment they received a
monthly stipend oftentimes they received
a car and a driver and they even had
access to dashas which were essentially
summer homes so they had a very very
high standard of living and winning the
Soviet championship just gave you
enormous enormous privilege in the
Soviet Union so there's Boris Spassky
playing in the Soviet championship and
usually was alongside the men's
championship the Soviets also hosted the
women's championships
okay so Spassky was sitting at dinner
with his coach his second Grandmaster
polish and Spassky does this so much
better than me so he's had dinner with
toh Lucien they're discussing their
strategy for the next game and in walks
this lady who was playing in the Soviet
championship with the women's and she
was an extremely foul mood very
temperamental
very angry she took her bird-like kind
of wound up and threw it on the floor
and sat down and a half so it's
something like money you know what has
happened today it's terrible I have lost
a horrible horrible game and I hate
myself and what's even worse is tomorrow
I have the black pieces against this
great rival and you know I'm distraught
I don't know what I'm going to do so
totally [ __ ] tomorrow your opponent will
play evil you must play e5 she will play
Knight up you must play knight c6 and
this goes on this heavy breathing as if
it's like natural she will play Bishop
to c4 not the Muay Lopez but the Italian
you will play 94
she will play Knight takes e5 you must
play Queen Sheba she would like Knight
takes f7 you won't play Queen take g2
you will play Queen takes e4 check she
will play Bishop b2 you will play Knight
f3 mate this one smashing and same scene
Boris Spassky world champion Boris
Spassky of having delicious cook so when
there comes a shamian takes told by the
cheeks the job Jason gets plants an
enormous kiss on him alright lets him go
and she turns with complete and utter
disdain towards Spassky you know that
she goes today I have won brilliantly
just as you know totally she told her
she looks as Spassky would complete this
game this day and discuss it says hot
such a coach I could be
let's go back to your question about the
Ruby Lopez for just a moment but this
was just a fantastic story I mean the
items and Spassky says it smells it so
much better but he's just hilarious very
very humor humor fell'd charming man
borås basket played among numerous
occasions and I I have a very very high
regard for him both as a chess player
but also is just a very wonderful
humanitarian person so II 45 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop b5 a c6 Bishop a4 now
look at the third so today this is
considered the main line and this is
probably what your opponents have done
and you probably can so this is all a
very very standard Theory not today
there are an enormous amount of ideas
for black black has been playing b5
Bishop b3 Bishop c5 he's been playing
the classical Bishop c5 he could play
what is called the open Spanish with
Knight takes d4 d4 d5 tisha b3 b5 this
is the open Spanish it's a big favor of
Viktor Korchnoi sand is a favorite of
bent Larsen and Larsen use the open
Spanish to beat Bobby Fischer in the
Piatigorsky cut took place in California
many many choices of what line of
defense black legs to play but consider
it the most common
as Bishop e7 this is the most common
defense white plays rook to e1 and now
white is indeed threatening to capture
capture capture as more piece defence
Queen d4 no longer works the knight
would retreat then once a whole pawn up
so the very standard moved today is b5
Bishop e3 whole new realm of this goes
into what is called the Marshall gambit
this is a gambit for black very famously
Frank Marshall who came up with this
conception had had welcome had had a
dream and Marshall kept a little
notebook with a pencil beside his bed
because he said you never know when an
inspiring idea might occur to you and he
wanted to write it down so according to
Marshall he had had a dream and he'd
been thinking about chess and he woke up
with this Marshall gambit in mind
he saved the Marshall gambit idea for
something like seven years and he played
the world champion Jose Road kappa
blanka and he sprung his opening
surprise that he had looked at for
literally years and Capablanca won the
game over the board
so today Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5
rotates be fine these are the standard
moves of the Marshall gambit and today
the modern move in the
gambit a c6 d for Bishop d6 group e1 and
literally hundreds of games have
continued like this if Marshall
Marshalls original conception which was
quite inventive I mean he was a
remarkable remarkable opening their
addition his original idea which he
played against kappa blanka was to
retreat his mind and what was his idea
his idea was that after the natural move
d4 bishop would come to d6 rook would
rob back then he would spring forward
with this night so that he would be
attacking the pawn on h2 and he would
follow it up with Queen h4 and as I
mentioned kappa blanka with withstood
this ferocious attack and then ended up
winning the game
so the marshall gambit today is one of
the favorite defenses of players like
michael adams and the world's number two
ranked player today Levon Aronian so
that's that's really important stuff one
of the greatest practitioners of the
black side the rulli Lopez is none other
than World Chess Champion a former world
champion Anatoly Karpov and he would
play the standard move D 76 and the idea
is to play Bishop g4 developing this
Bishop White's a stage three councils
and now we get to a whole new gamut of
chest offenses for black black has a
very wide variety of choices in this
position that solis me slob is part of
age seven eight oh
did i do right HD cancels d4 yeah h7
h6 is I cheated good
hope I didn't you so h6 is a move Bishop
e7 is a move 85 is a movie there's just
a whole variety of moves rookie okay I
do apologize let me just make sure
so Bishop e5 e6 Bishop 84 kind of things
castles Bishop e7 rook e1 v 5 it should
be 3 d6 see-through castles from Age 3
yes so I have cheated black from so we
have this position and it is like to
move so Bishop d7 and rookie ate his
basically Carlos variation also known as
as I said the oldest variation in the
ruie is attributed to Michael chip chip
Goran as you may remember he was a
challenger to Wilhelm steinitz world
champion
and the chigorin variation basically
starts in this position with lots and
lots of games from this position Knight
bd2 and what white is intentions are to
bring his Knight to g3 somewhere if we
just put one of the main variations on
the board the fidgets going it's very
very difficult for both players in terms
of what their overall plants might be
both players tend to be very very
flexible in their thinking for example
in some cases black wants to capture the
pawn on d4 and quick very quickly bring
a book on to the C file so then he could
attack these bishop unseen to white for
his part main very oftentimes consider
the movie four and five so what's the
idea of d4 d5 it's basically to
artificially isolate this night this
night suddenly if this night has to end
up retreating to the beat to the square
of b7 you'll notice that it doesn't have
a very good circuit the knight would
actually end up being very much out of
the game so against the move d4 d5 which
I recommend by the way a light gave me
space black has to be very quick in
bringing the Knight to c4 his idea is
quite simply that his knight would be
better placed on d7 than on b7 okay from
this type of a position
it's very common for white to look
towards the Kingston and to develop an
initiative on the kingside well if you
think about it and how are you going to
develop initiative up in Jackson
if white could magically end it
illegally you need to move f2f for what
that would be quite good because that
could have opened up lines of attack so
it's very often that white plays mean
nighttime f/32 age to whites idea is to
play the move f2f for some time team
wants to play the move Queen f3 with the
threat of Bishop takes h6 and sometimes
he wants to jump with his Knight to g4
thanks to his advantage in the center in
space the position is considered to
lights advantage and the idea is that
white wants to go King side and black
thanks to his edge on the Queen side he
wants to do some things on the on the
Queen side for example sometimes black
place 4 C 5 C 4 and in case of b 480p
fine and normal normally this night ends
up going to this square d7 so that in
case and form we can trade it with our
night on the square
but the question is about some openings
I don't want to keep you too long
Queens gambit declined okay we'll go
back for a moment for the Queens gambit
declined I have been a longtime
practitioner of the Queens gambit
declined as black I think that it's one
of the one of the most stable defenses
against 1.d4 and I had a pretty good
overall success with it but even more
importantly I I haven't been gonna let
say crushed early in fact usually in
case I lose it's because my phone that
had was forced to play a pretty darn
good game so it'd be 45 c4 e6 these are
the standard moves of the Queens gambit
declined and today what's very
interesting is that Emmanuel blasters so
far these are all very very standard
moves and Emmanuel Lasker's creating
maneuver the so called creaming maneuver
has become one of the most popular
features in bang bastard play so if we
take a look at this position for just a
second
it's not Monday Night Football and it's
something happening and we take a look
at this position from whites point of
view over just a second
whites rather a pea from the space count
he has two four six eight nine ten and
from blacks point of view black only
attacks two of these words with this
bone and two of these squares with his
Knight so blacks behind in space there
are none so from what blaster did this
he said a space advantage is only
important if there are a lot of pieces
on the board if a lot of the pieces come
off the ward the advantage and space is
reduced so last year like to play the
move Knight f-16 okay so obviously
bishops are in contact now the bishops
who traded office please now it was it
it was established that Knight takes em
for D takes e4 92 f5 sorry let me just
put that on the board was not a cause of
concern for the second player in other
words the second player got a pretty
reasonable game
in this position if you trade he would
take afford maybe play knight c6 and
Knight takes and blacks position was in
Grandmaster practice proven to be quite
right so what became the major moves was
rook c1 now after looks move on
Knight takes rook takes so from blacks
point of view having traded a pair of
pieces off the board and well okay white
still has is my sanctuary he still has
an edge and space and a very surprising
move became very popular thanks to a
manual asker what last four did was he
play c6 essentially I think it's mission
is on that one I beg your pardon
what Lasker's is essentially saying it's
your turn go ahead and make your best
move if you trade pawns you'll open up
this lights great vision for me feels
you'll help me so white said well I'll
develop my vision what last three did
was he traded trade 97 we understand
this Bishop is a problem and this is how
he self is Bishop and his move castles
Laska didn't see ghosts so in case of
the capture capture capture captured we
see that Lasker's next move is he's
going to play Bishop e6 and completely
neutralized the position once he gets to
the Bishop e6 and rook b8 there's no
advantage whatsoever in the position for
white and so this today this variation
has become one of the popular ways for
black to neutralize one d4 and a lot of
players are no longer playing Bishop g5
that they're playing Bishop that for
very early on move
you